il sera question de littérature dans
quelques minutes avec le premier livre
de Thierry jaglave Linois bonsoir vous
êtes venu sur le plateau nous présenter
histoire d'homme c'est cet ouvrage on va
en parler dans un instant c'est votre
premier roman pour l'instant les images
des 10 ans de l'estaminet à Manille elle
est un mot avec un concert très
inattendu du parrain de la salle le
musicien Bernard Lubin une soirée
totalement décalée
l'estaminet le café culture de
Magny-les-Hameaux fêtait samedi c'est 10
ans une soirée concert placée
volontairement sous le signe de
l'improvisation et pour l'occasion le
parrain Bernard lubbat est venu avec son
acolyte Jean-Pierre Drouet pour jouer
une musique aux gens indescriptible à
l'aide d'instruments parfois très
insolites là le public aujourd'hui il va
être qu'est-ce que je pense de ça
qu'est-ce qui se passe parce que c'est
pas du rock c'est pas du jazz c'est pas
dodo
décalé délurés débrider les adjectifs ne
manquent pas pour qualifier la
performance du duo complice depuis 2002
l'estaminet multiplie les genres
éclectiques on a aussi bien eu du ciné
pour pour des bébés de trois semaines et
puis on a des choses aussi pour tous les
âges et aussi pour tous les goûts et
tous les publics le prochain spectacle
gazouillis petit oiseau se jouera le 9
février à 20h30 pour les enfants des
deux ans avec toujours une politique
tarifaire très accessible un carnet de
10 places coûte 40 euros
bonsoir bons idées dans les Yvelines à
Voisins le bretonneux
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous êtes sur
l'auteur d'histoire d'hommes hommes avec
un S avant même de parler de cette
ouvrage un mot sur vous sur votre
parcours écrivant c'est pas votre
profession à la base je suis pas
écrivain de profession je travaille je
suis de formation comptable ouais tout à
fait comment s'est fait la bascule pour
passer des chiffres aux lettres oh ben
sans trop de difficultés c'est une envie
forte de vouloir faire cet exercice de
l'écriture et à un moment important de
ma vie et voilà il y a toujours un
déclic forcément lorsqu'on se met à
écrire quel a été le déclic pour vous le
déclic c'était l'envie de raconter des
émotions l'envie de faire tomber un peu
un masque à montrer autre chose que
l'image d'un comptable justement vous
écriviez déjà auparavant plutôt des
poèmes et là vous avez décidé la forme
du roman de passer par la forme du roman
on va regarder un petit peu plus près ce
livre l'histoire de Nicolas 40 ans il
fait face à son passé après le retour
d'un père qui pour ainsi dire quasiment
jamais connu ça c'est pour le point de
départ et ensuite et bien ensuite le
fait divers qui se produit dans sa vie à
savoir son père qui va venir à sa
rencontre et va avoir un accident de
voiture va amener Nicolas à devoir se
repositionner par rapport à son parcours
à sa vie à ses choix il va devoir se
reconstruire et ça va pas être chose
forcément facile pour lui c'est un roman
sombre abandon trahison crime ou
épargnez pas grand chose
différents personnages c'est un style un
petit peu difficile justement que vous
avez choisi c'est difficile mais il y a
beaucoup d'espoir dans le roman ça ça
retrace la vie ça retrace le quotidien
de beaucoup de personnes non non il y a
de l'espoir comment vous écrivez
justement par exemple sur ces
différentes ces différentes scènes vous
vous déroulez l'écriture vous vous dites
non ça c'est pas crédible je vais
reprendre le fil comment vous travaillez
j'écoute déjà ce qui se passe autour de
moi j'écoute les nouvelles les
informations les faits divers et puis je
les mélange avec ma propre expérience ma
propre vie
et puis j'essaye de rester dans quelque
chose de très crédible pour que tout le
monde puisse un petit peu si reconnaître
et se poser des questions justement la
lecture c'est un petit peu l'approche
que je veux proposer au lecteur c'est de
se poser des questions de se mettre un
peu à la place du des personnages
rajouter en crédibilité justement où
vous faites très attention à l'ordre
chronologique un petit peu chaque petite
séquence on va dire débute par un jour
un horaire il faut que ce soit
millimétré c'est une enquête oui tout à
fait oui tout à fait et puis c'est aussi
lié à mon style à mon ma façon de
décrire
j'écris un peu partout dans les
transports notamment donc il faut que
j'ai des repères aussi tout simplement
et ça se ressent effectivement dans le
déroulement de l'histoire on a toujours
autour de ces repères ça aussi c'est une
constante un petit peu à travers
l'ouvrage il y a toujours le repère de
musique quelquefois une musique qui
passe un film qui est diffusé aussi ça
c'est pourquoi c'est pour accrocher le
lecteur dans un monde dans un
environnement qu'il connaît aussi très
contemporain parce que c'est des
références oui oui parce que c'est un
peu mon passé c'est un petit peu mon
histoire donc oui c'est les musiques qui
m'ont un petit peu bercer dans les
années 80 on va dire justement c'est là
où je voulais vous emmener c'est votre
histoire un petit peu il y a une partie
de d'auto biographie dans quelle mesure
dans une très faible mesure disons que
comme le personnage du roman
j'ai un père qui a quitté le domicile
conjugal un jour et je l'ai pas revu
pendant près de 30 ans plus de 30 ans et
le déclic à l'écriture ça a été c'est
retrouvailles 30 ans après son départ et
ça m'a permis de libérer un petit peu la
parole par l'écrit alors ça libérer la
parole mais pour autant vous n'avez pas
fait une autobiographie romancer aussi
c'est pourquoi c'est pour garder une
distance aussi avec votre histoire tout
à fait je pense que pour
faire une autobiographie faut des choses
beaucoup plus fortes à raconter moi
c'est presque banal quelque part en 2000
en 2012 c'est devenu une situation
banale la séparation d'un couple en 75
76 c'était pas ça c'était pas quelque
chose de très court donc
ça pour autant ça ne méritait pas une
autobiographie le romancée pour moi est
beaucoup plus facile agréable et ça
laisse libre
cours à mon imagination et puis vous
l'avez dit aussi tout à l'heure ce n'est
pas un drame il y a de l'espoir dans ce
livre il y a de l'espoir c'est ce que
vous vouliez mettre en avant
véritablement histoire d'hommes éditions
teles et c'est un livre pour lequel vous
vous êtes véritablement investi vous
êtes mis à compte d'auteur pour ce livre
tout à fait c'est à dire que
concrètement comment ça fonctionne ce
compte d'auteur bah vous financez une
partie du projet vous financez la
publication du roman et vous faites
aider par une maison d'édition qui vous
propose un service à part entière et qui
a une fois qu'il a mis en se passe le
livre la matière le support
vous aide un petit peu dans la démarche
pour faire connaître
le roman et maintenant que le bébé est
là histoire d'hommes et donc sortir il
est disponible vous êtes satisfait
satisfait pardon le papa est fier oui
oui il y a toujours des imperfections
toujours des choses qu'on voudrait
refaire mais il y a un moment il faut il
faut tourner la page si je peux dire et
puis aller laisser vivre le bébé et pour
vous c'est une nouvelle carrière alors
non vous allez tourner la page vous
allez écrire à nouveau sur votre thème
peut-être je suis en train d'écrire un
deuxième roman oui
mais pour l'instant non ça reste une un
plaisir une passion ce sera sur quoi le
deuxième roman voulait pas le dire
encore pas encore donc
en tout cas vous ne manquez pas
d'inspiration voilà le deuxième roman
devrait arriver et vous reviendrez sur
votre plateau pour en parler bien sûr
elle tirage avec ce livre histoire
d'homme édition teles merci à vous merci
le 7 8 va se poursuivre dans un instant
ce sera la de l'innovation nous allons
vous parler du LIFI cette technologie
pour diffuser des informations à travers
la lumière auparavant le rappel des
titres de ce 5 février opération
débrayage pour les salariés du
Technocentre Renault à Guyancourt
environ 150 personnes rassemblées
pendant une heure de vent ce site
l'affaire Dominici revu et corrigé par
des étudiants en droit de l'Université
de Versailles Saint-Quentin ils ont
reconstitué le procès qui en 1957 avait
condamné à mort Gaston et Dominici
surprise à l'issue des plaidoiries
l'accusation 2013 a été réfutée le lycée
connaissez-vous cette technique de
communication sans fil basée sur la
lumière une façon de ne plus utiliser
les ondes électromagnétiques des
chercheurs d'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin ont créé une start-up pour
développer leur procédés et nous allons
en parler dans un instant les 10 ans de
l'estaminet à Magny-les-Hameaux avec un
concert très inattendu du parrain de la
salle le musicien Bernard Luba une
soirée totalement décalée
nouvelle série de débrayage aujourd'hui
chez Renault les salariés de Flins dans
les Yvelines étaient mobilisés des
appels à la grève également lancé afin
de dénoncer l'accord de compétitivité
proposée par la direction et qui prévoit
jusqu'à 8000 suppressions de postes et
éventuellement des fermetures de sites
c'est ce que craignent les syndicats et
les syndicats sont d'autant plus
remontés que le ministre Arnaud
Montebourg elle les invite à signer cet
accord
salariés de Renault et salarié des
sociétés de prestations entrons en
résistance le message a fédéré ce matin
entre 150 et 180 salariés du
Technocentre Renault de Guyancourt
l'enjeu protesté encore contre la
direction qui tiendrait selon les
syndicats un discours volontairement
catastrophiste pour effectuer des
recules sociaux sur les 7500
suppressions de postes annoncées 2000
concernent les cadres une catégorie de
personnels qui n'a pas forcément l'âme
militante
à la fois mobilisés et démobilisés
mobilisés parce que bien sûr ils sont
inquiets par tout ce qui est on va leur
proposer et puis des mobiliser parce que
ils sont dégoûtés d'être traités de
cette façon là avec
un coup ils sont les meilleurs et puis
un coup ils sont mauvais ils sont trop
nombreux et ils sont trop payés quoi
parmi les manifestants ce matin Noël
d'Orient ingénieur chez Renault depuis
1987 il estime que le diagnostic de la
direction est erronée depuis le début
l'indicateur a surveillé lui en priorité
c'est la productivité qu'il résume ainsi
produire plus en travaillant moins il
vient de remettre différents syndicats
un dossier d'une cinquantaine de pages
où il détaille ses propres contre
propositions en misant sur le
développement des véhicules d'entrée de
gamme moi ce que je propose dans le
document c'est qu'on devienne le
Microsoft de l'automobile c'est-à-dire
la celui qui est le moins cher et qui
fabrique un produit standard et on se
pose plus de questions quand on veut une
voiture et qu'on n'y connaît rien en
voiture on achète à Sandero mais par
contre on la produit en France parce
qu'on a des usines les plus productives
et donc on sait la produire pas cher en
France alors effectivement ça fait
baisser la main d'oeuvre directe mais au
moins on garde les usines en France et
on aura autour tout ce qui est service
tout ce qui est conception des véhicules
qui restent en France en attendant
d'obtenir des réponses Noël d'Orient
reste
mobilisé la marque les syndicats eux
aimeraient étendre leur mouvement à
l'ensemble de la filière automobile la
direction de Renault à quant à elle
annoncé le versement d'une prime à
l'intéressement fin février cela ne
changera rien pour nous prévient
Christophe Delaine
et nous sommes allés demander à Alain
Schmitz le président du Conseil général
des Yvelines président UMP ce qu'il
pensait de l'avenir de l'automobile
notamment dans le département le
département qui aide toutes ces
entreprises je suis inquiet sur
l'industrie automobile française
dans les Yvelines pas forcément plus
qu'ailleurs au contraire je pense que
les Yvelines ont beaucoup d'atouts en
revanche qui s'est produit au nez peut
se produire partout ailleurs je crois
que nous sommes à la merci
d'un effondrement actuel du marché
européen donc du marché français d'où la
nécessité de produire hors de France et
hors d'Europe pour les deux grands
groupes français et que ça repose en
termes stratégique la remise en cause de
leur implantation sur toute un ensemble
de sites à l'intérieur de l'Hexagone
alors oui peut-être pourquoi pas ce qui
s'est produit à Aulnay peut se produire
par tout ailleurs nous ne sommes
certainement pas à l'abri de d'une telle
décision j'allais dire de la part des
décideurs l'atout que nous avons c'est
qu'en termes de recherche et de
développement et PSA et Renault sont
implantés durablement dans les Yvelines
avec l'effort que nous ont pour
installer vdcom sur le plateau de satori
j'ai tout espoir tout me laisse à penser
que ces deux groupes privilégieront les
sites les noix nous serons présents
salon de Genève là où elle mars prochain
puisque dans le cadre de la R&D nous
avons aidé aux véhicules innovants
véhicules du futur véhicule électrique
véhicules comment j'allais dire
intelligent voilà on est en poursuit
cette action à travers justement la
création de petites entreprises
innovantes